the scene at a girls school in Iran's
Capital yesterday one girl after another
has helped coughing and spluttering to a
waiting ambulance
School across the country since November
girls have been allegedly poisoned by
gas with no explanation why
we've been given an interview with a
schoolgirl in Northwest Iran by a Human
Rights group we've re-voiced it to
protect her identity
[Music]
they gassed our score we don't feel safe
inside they had taken down the CCTV in
the past two to three weeks since
yesterday they've released gas inside
our school and several of my own friends
have fallen sick
she's one of hundreds of witnesses who
claim girls are left gasping for air
dizzy and nauseous
like this group in Tehran yesterday
after gas appears to have been released
into their schools
they did not let us leave until the
school time was over the gas was still
there but they didn't allow us go home
the gas attacks follow months of
protests against Iran's regime often led
by women some say the government is
responsible trying to close down the
schools which have become the focus of
unrest others say their Revenge carried
out by elements within the regime the
country's supreme leader has spoken out
to condemn the attacks
foreign officials must pursue this
seriously it's an important matter if
there are people or groups involved this
is a big and unforgivable crime but the
government is accused of trying to cover
up the attacks by those like the mother
of a nine-year-old girl caught in
another alleged gas attack again we're
protecting her identity
forces arrived at the school and ordered
the personnel and the teachers not to
talk about the attack and should say the
smell of the gas and the poisoning of
the students was because of a burst in
the central heating pipes if someone
asked
Iran was already gripped by fear in the
wake of months of repression and unrest
Arenas must now cope with what appears
to be a concerted effort to poison their
children
Dominic wagorn Sky News